hello and welcome to zero playing the Z
integrator that's not a good score two
wins and 6 losses okay no name I think
right I don't that one earlier and this
is an interesting line that nobody plays
I don't know why Queen you for ticks on
c3 as interesting
hmm this is also possible I guess
slightly irritated yeah it takes you
three what's happening there knight c6 I
guess do I have some wacky night a 20
that's a very strange stuff and now i
can take this and Queen d2 I think this
is actually something that i had
analyzed when i worked for my when I
when I work my booger Queen d2 we can
play or between D to a queen bee to I
think they both work it seems that he
did not go into this knowing what's
what's going on ok so what here I'm
losing something back the question is
how exactly am I going to do that Bishop
a five Queen takes I can go create high
of takes Queen takes and yeah grab a
pawn essentially for a very good
compensation for wide I don't know if I
want to do that Queen f6 is also
possible that that wins more material
but it's super risky ok I'm grabbing and
grabbing this pawn that i mentioned CP
Queen takes Queen before check Knight
takes before it's definite compensation
for white but well Jack I have to I have
to go with something I cannot spell
and even longer so um okay you will put
it on these six so probably here
or c5 is also an option
now White has compensation I'm not sure
that he has more than that but enough
for porn absolutely so we should a 6-1
taking now yep what has some at least
enough also for one particular reason
you can always I mean this is not what
you should do but you can always just
take one c64 completely um George kind
of ending okay so i have to go before
here my four is a good news ok anyway if
i take if i take it and then I cannot
cancel whatever what the [ __ ] I don't
want to I cannot castle I'm I'm thinking
and I guess oh well I cannot do that yes
probably means i have to go before here
right well okay i somehow untangle like
takes rook takes it says compensation
too strong yeah
yeah maybe now if I after c5 if I just
take I think white has enough but not
more I have to take on c5 it seems he
took with the rook why did she do that
anyway
I am still not losing straightaway hear
that how much is clear I think when I
analyze this for my book I didn't want
to take the pawn before but don't quite
remember prince2 is an an unknown line
which is quite interesting ok so now
night before Bishop a8 king of seven ok
let's let's go for something and now on
95 f 1
not shown 86th of course also possible
95 496 okay
still holding on a fortnight see for now
maybe you can go look see 794 check and
yeah but I thought this would work rook
c8 time morning my trip management xe4
chick takes check can takes Bishop takes
a for hangs and 94 the threat he might
check my night somehow but Andrew k7 as
a move maybe look at 7s the problem hmm
check
maybe I can go look c6
miraculously continuing the game this is
probably working though jagged chicken
cannot take their rook v6 I guess check
now he takes it yep check check check
it's not so easy now take worth of this
okay look g7 what the high what the heck
and this one I blundering a 6 oops check
its to a real acquisition and check I
can chat something you is absolutely no
time the dome a light foreheads I'm time
nope and it's reading a book age to mate
now what is happening in same I ok here
i am i just losing i know it was just a
completely wacky scramble the engine
wants to go where then I'm not losing
right it wants to go g4 here and check
now okay this is several i really wonder
y SI engine giving widen advantage here
that gets g5 and okay check incoming
challenge me no I don't want a rematch
in blitz this camp maybe white can try
to win but I doubt it yeah I was
certainly losing before I am there were
a couple of wacky wacky moments he
definitely had a super strong
compensation I thought you should just
take with the bishop but maybe rook
takes us even stronger and if six all
this looks totally normal I'm actually
happy that I somehow yeah could could
continue for so long it was very tough
to defend under pressure Luke is seven
yeah i was thinking that this this could
be as what this is strong jinx is room
check if i take it I'm not going to yeah
I have not getting trapped I'm getting
trapped very nicely and here here is
playing this and again yeah I have no I
have no squares you just wraps my night
which is what I kind of suspected that
this might happen the after night takes
I can still continue even though it's
not much fun yeah this should lose
Bishop f1 still at least the fight even
though why this batter ok and here Jay
I'm losing check check yeah I'm actually
blundering a fool okay you can just take
it can play Knight b6 was actually but I
was just
was just firing here 96 is a double
attack check in 95 didn't work but I
didn't really I just was just was just
playing I think um i would need to look
it up I'm absolutely positive that I had
this in my book I think I don't know
that the engine now gives come to see
several which makes some sense yeah yeah
this is this is definitely interesting
and hear something like this I think
this was the line that I happen to book
I'm not completely sure I would need to
we need to look it up okay well thanks
for watching